priyanka chopra loves working with hubby
nick jonas but of course there's always
exceptions it's crazy in a new interview
with variety the actress opens up about
her marriage and while the power couple
loves a good collab duets are a no-go
priyanka explains i love working with
nick so you'll see things happen as the
years unfold but i'll never sing with
him and when reminded she's a proven
singer herself priyanka replies not like
him and goes on to call her love a
musical prodigy
oh well at least there's a few other
projects in the pipeline for one their
first fashion partnership sharing the
news to instagram last week the couple
says creating memories and special
moments is something we are deeply
passionate about doing in our everyday
lives and now we have the pleasure of
doing that in our new business venture i
have a lot of faith in who my husband is
and i know i have a lot of faith in
the rock that he is for our family but
their best projects so far becoming
parents
earlier this year nick and priyanka
welcomed their first child daughter
multi-marie chopra jonas
and when speaking with e.t recently nick
opened up about fatherhood how's
fatherhood been for you because
everybody says it's life-changing to you
it is certainly life-changing she's uh
she's amazing um brings me a lot of joy
all is good
little malty's name pays homage to
priyanka's indian heritage
malty in sanskrit means small fragrant
flower or moonlight it's a special thing
in march we learned more about how the
duo is adapting to life as mom and dad
e.t source explained nick and priyanka
love being new parents and have been
spending a lot of down time at home the
source added priyanka and nick are
private but have let close friends and
family meet their baby you know you love
seeing your your family happy yeah nick
and priyanka won't be hitting high notes
together anytime soon but nick tells et
they're still putting in the work to
plant the music bug in their little one
has your sweet daughter
heard any of your music yet have you
played anything for her a few things
okay uh and i i sing to her you know i
love singer and um
yeah you know it's it's beautiful what
what's on the playlist are you singing
love bug i never thought that i'd catch
this
love bug
uh no i'm singing just a lot of you know
old classics
my wife kind of plays her more of a
stuff that's on the ipod or whatever but
i think
[Music]